they did a daily second for a dating
segment for me on the show called
chinder we had thousands of women just
throwing themselves yeah i ain't looking
for that though you know i like i like
being alone as well too you know
hey man you know you know yeah
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
if your brother yeah if your brother
cared about you he'd get you something
like this yeah he really would man
[Laughter]
and i'm gonna say that i don't mean that
in a bad way this is kind of like an
intervention bro
we're here to help you out okay man it
seems like you're an abusive
relationship
yeah let's talk about that i want to go
first and foremost yeah
yeah i just i had to get some things off
my chest too because i
people hit me up about the crying thing
is it okay if i talk about it on air
please do it thank you so much because i
you know every day every day
every day hey why'd you cry why'd you
cry
yeah i love how your feet don't touch
the ground man
yeah we're small dudes yeah oh me meet
him at 105.
what do you what do you weigh about 35.
yeah he's still growing though man how
old are you 15 16.
yeah but you could still grow dude yeah
he'll do anything coming up love new
treatments get a new head
yeah never say never doug every
procedure somewhat titanium or steel
thing to give you
yeah it's a nightmare but you can't have
long if you had long legs
you wouldn't your head would be small
and then your arms you look like a t-rex
i feel like i got long arms for my body
actually yeah you could go another
you could go another four inches on each
leg but your head will be small so
that's the issue you're gonna run to
then
and you can't add unless you do a head
adder like a head weight
like an additional head maybe a little
hgh grow that head out doug
i tried i tried to get some
some kid did it in our high school when
his chest grew like really big all the
bones in his chest and he had like a
dyna he looked like a dinosaur and then
he died in a
truck accident not a car accident truck
yeah hghs that real [ __ ] man you don't
be doing that in high school dude
yeah like always like my senior year it
was uh my senior year i wanted to do it
because i was a middle linebacker at 100
oh wow
nobody believed you were a middle
linebacker
yeah and no shade bro i mean you're
still growing was this eight man
football or were we talking big boy
it was actually a d i played like maybe
two three games varsity my senior year i
played like
one or two jv but i'm in one or two
junior year
it was mainly jv but it was a d1 it was
like one of the top football schools in
our
state now they uh and let's don't refer
to rhode island as a state overall yeah
i mean i get it but let's don't do it
but um the big thing is that you guys
um you um you went to college
like for a year and a half yeah yeah so
yeah got what i needed to get yeah
trust me i work with brendan's top
future the in and out policy
bernie's the only person i know that
went to the drive-through out of college
once
did you go to college no no i'll do you
a song he went to semester at
c i went to two
yeah dude he said margaritas worked at
senior frogs and got a degree
it shames me man senior frog is the
worst where they like
where they put that liquor in your
stepdad and then hurt his neck
[ __ ] and then she shakes her kids [ __ ]
dude
um all right meatball dude close it up
man
good luck with your football career man
yeah i would have done you solid when
you told me your middle linebacker like
let's let's go ahead and quit that dude
yeah this is your joe broken moment
where we tell you you got to quit it
yeah i think i think you'd be surprised
you'd be surprised what you can do i
think brianna like would [ __ ] you up
for the naalp bro national advancement a
little people dude
what i'm saying is you cannot get leg
extensions man no
because what you don't realize is and
can you get one more photo of him nick
so that we can get this correct
and i'm saying this out of love and man
i was went to church recently so it's
coming
you know they let you back in i thought
there was a training order well this is
a different church
all right and this is not coming just
for me obviously
if you get like extensions your head is
going to be too small
you look like the security off mario
bros bring that [ __ ] up nick
is that a real thing yeah the mario bros
the movie they're real big and they have
tiny little heads
great movie in the early 90s dude
amistad is a great movie i don't think
we want to
put a lot of these things into the same
bin but we could let we could we'll see
what we're trying to head super mario's
movie
yeah there he is that's what you're
going to look like so you need to get
hgh then
we'll get you on something it does look
like i'd love to get on it you would
yeah oh we'll usually get you doug let's
get you on that gold's gym stack and see
how juicy we can get you it'd be a great
experiment for the show
did you yeah oh then you're halfway
there you're halfway there go in the
locker room and just have an injection
in your ass
no don't go so deal you used to do
remember you got all juicy yeah that was
when i was looking field's ass
that's when i was a child yeah trust me
it's the one place that's that that it
stays is in the butt
yeah i mean it could be you m dude
yeah it could be you how much do you
think you could put on honestly and
still look
like a like i know like a safe guy for
people to like to for a dad to let
his daughter go out i want you to get to
200.
200 yeah i was thinking like 150 max oh
dude what kind of
waste of time dude yeah i mean like i
don't want to look like those like you
you always see those like short cartel
guys that are leafy as [ __ ]
it just looks weird for me yeah that's
what we want yet though all right then
i'll do it hell yeah
see that's the dedication you need out
of him but i want to see your bone
structure grow like this fella in our
high school named gene and he died
his bones grew real big and then he died
but he died in a car accident or truck
accident
now your feet are also going to grow on
hgh perfect because i
i mean what do you say seven seven and a
half don't guess a man's
shoe size that's gay all right i'm sorry
but i was close one night
he was yeah
but yeah it looks like about a seven
probably but um
okay cool let's get into this show i
don't know what we're talking about
anymore
well operation juice heads happening
though and summer's coming up it's a
thick boy summer so let's get on it
it's a white boy summer and i want to
know how do you feel about that stevie
weeby's in here today what's up brother
hey what's going on thanks for having me
man
yeah thanks for doing this man is it is
it filming
oh yeah okay i just want to get a couple
things off my chest
i know last time it didn't like no one
was here
but i didn't cry okay because i've been
getting hit up
my brother said oh he cried but it's
like you know
when my girl broke up with me yeah i
cried you know how long ago was that
i don't know a couple months it's been
about four or five and why did she leave
you
[ __ ] we just kind of like you know but
going back to this it's like i was i was
more mad at your
parking guy oh he's a real stick what's
wrong especially if he has to take a
[ __ ] he
he needs the money man he changed his
story real quick yeah
yeah and take me through some of that
stevie okay we're excited
you know we went to starbucks i'm like
oh [ __ ] this is gonna be tight
and then we got here an hour and a half
early
and that's a very senior citizen move i
will say that
yeah and so uh i found the door
and i noticed i looked at the bottom and
it was it was dark and i'm like oh
they're probably
setting up this sounds like a side quest
on final fantasy are you sure that this
isn't it it was dark it was dark it was
dark you found it
don't you have a male like hole in the
middle of the door yeah would you have
this
i'm like i'm gonna look through that and
then i looked and then i only saw
it shine in the back i'm like oh that's
not a good sign
and so i called is his name nick yeah
unfortunately i was hitting up nick and
then he just told me oh he completely
forgot yeah
[ __ ] yeah but i didn't cry dude you know
i was upset but well how upset were you
scaled one to ten
i wasn't upset you guys no how could you
be no
because i haven't even met you yeah i
know you don't know each other yeah yeah
yeah just you know you're a great guy
hold on
you don't know if he's a great guy
bernie you can't just say that no i'm
pretty i have a pretty good read
yeah and she's a nice guy but his
girlfriend left him for a reason
all right no judgment i know i was
trying to get inside and i shouldn't
have said that and i was it the same
girlfriend that i remember when i came
over to your place that time
very sweet little girl wears like a lot
of like she can wear like little hats
and stuff
yeah oh yeah i would guess yes i don't
think there's she's a good person
yeah she's cute yeah oh she was so cute
and how long were you together
four and a half oh that's yeah
yeah yeah and what ethnicity was she she
was filipina
pinoy yeah man cute man yeah four and a
half
yeah you know how that goes and you know
are you familiar with filipino either
they're traditional you know
yes so i was in google family i'm not
gonna
i'm okay to sit here and be in this
conversation i don't want lies to go on
he has no idea what you're saying
well well all my employees are asian
yeah yeah well chin's korean chin's
korean yeah
vietnamese vietnamese yeah yeah yeah
okay right there let's say guessing
so um there's some asian involved he
also has some very dark asians i would
call them i thought i thought i was
in with the family i thought i was good
oh he came out of left field was just
like i can't do that no
you know what it's the father the father
do you think it's out or do you think
it's another guy
it's been a few months so i feel like we
can talk about this um
that i don't know i don't know how do
you do you fall on instagram
you know how to do the reason you know i
don't know how to private investigate on
the the institute you know how you could
find out
oh she followed yeah i don't know my man
nick could
you want to do that though because if
you go down that road then what are you
you're not over isn't it yeah you're not
gonna get her back
yeah i just had to let it go oh she
wanted to she was always in
relationships she and she was like she
wanted to do her own thing so i just i
sometimes you have to let the bird fly
away yeah yeah filipino bird man
sometimes dude you gotta freaking clip
them wings
catch that [ __ ] and have lunch you know
what i'm saying dude so like let them
wing so they don't get all crazy
catch that bird floating yeah yeah it
was tough and uh
she wanted to do it we got back together
but then um and then she did it again
and i'm like oh i can't do she broke up
with you again
but then she came back the next day and
then we try to mend it and then how old
is she
oh she's a lot she's young younger how
young are we talking
27 oh thank god okay when you say young
no no no no
no i'm out with that young dude
not like that i hear like somebody like
getting called out for like
and a 4.0 gpa today you know
captain of the senior swim team like you
got to make sure you say how old
yeah 27 she's 28 now she's 20.
maybe some growing to do did you feel a
lot of times like
you were the father in the relationship
or no
no okay because i you know i'm i'm
really immature for
you know my energy would you think maybe
you're playing too many video games
catch that flick how'd you know that i
just you know
everybody knows yeah that too that she
was living it
with me uh for a while and i would play
destiny
yeah about six eight hours a day well at
night and then she would be trying cause
i live in a studio
and she would be trying to sleep yeah
and see what's crazy is her destiny was
getting some rest
yeah yeah yours was beating a video you
know you know i had the headphones on
and
it doesn't help the buttons get so loud
yeah so yeah that it is what it is
they chose the video game over the girl
my man well he didn't do that
yeah i mean i messed that up i miss that
that that aspect of well let's go
through
one thing real quick because look man
everybody in here has been
dumped recently by someone or is going
to get probably done by their wife in
the next couple of years
and yeah what i want to say is that do
you think
what are your regrets if you have any
and then i'll tell you some of my
regrets
she's man and also we said this guy
busted out a bird and i'll tell you this
he
had a he did like a not a floss
like a thread that he kept the bird and
that's how they kept it instead of cage
he
kept it down to a nail and hooked it to
its leg that's kind of cool
this is before they had cages they would
go in circles huh you'd go in circles
yeah we'll just go out and come back
real quick that's crazy but on the
weekends you give it about eight feet of
line yeah
yeah yeah it's not terrible i didn't
think it was terrible at all i need to
take it outside you could put the nail
anywhere that's the difference i've got
the cage is so limiting think people
think that cage oh it's so great no
can't do much but you get that line you
can do that you can do that
yeah so you have some regrets maybe
maybe yeah
yeah maybe it's like she wanted to move
at one time and i wasn't ready to you
know how i
i failed that test major she wanted to
move where yeah
well i lived it i live in a studio i
have rent control i live in a studio
okay so you're blm what does that mean
huh
yeah okay so yeah i had that going on so
there was a moment where she wanted to
move in
or move no like get a place together wow
and so what happened
i was stubborn no i don't want to move
that was a mistake
i know now i could see that yeah and
how oh i remember the night it was like
almost
like an ultimatum and i i failed that
test i i was
yeah i failed that test it breaks my
heart because i've been there man where
we don't want to change what we're doing
and we don't see
i'm molded a certain way you know what i
mean i'm like a man child kind of in a
way like i
i you know i play i play warzone yeah oh
yeah
yeah it's easy to see and uh i'd love to
see her
i'd love to see a picture i'll show you
off camera can you draw a good picture
everything
yeah if we can't bring it up could you
draw it can you get us a little bit of
paper and pen when you chin this is one
of your freaking friends in here
dude i don't know if i could i don't
know if i could do it right
and if you describe her to a we'll all
draw her i don't want to leave her i
don't want her to not to be here even in
spirit
yeah but you know one thing i did out of
respect is you know how like a lot of
like when you podcast i never brought
her on camera i
you know what i mean i left that
identity yeah man like i
kept that portion out of my life and it
doesn't feel like you're exposing or
anything it just feels like you know but
it's good to kind of talk about what
happened man
and especially if you came here there
was rumors yeah the guy said you were
crying
here's here's the report that we got
first of all from the
management just give it just give it to
give it to me here's the thing
sorry go ahead and i hate to say this
there's a japanese woman crying outside
of your building that's what they said
dude yeah that's the report we got the
first of all
and what did you when you when you first
got it would i i didn't know i i i was
confused
they said there's a japanese woman
sobbing at your studio
my intern was with me he could testify
no we were just talking and we're trying
to figure things out but
that wasn't me man well that was
something that was not me
was anybody else here at the same time
maybe some other japanese women
maybe nick makes it up again maybe we
had a japanese person what did you think
when you got that message
from him no from the security uh
i didn't hear from him i heard from
stevie that he was like he's not letting
me out no we got
we got whenever we get the message from
the security people that there's a
japanese woman crying outside of you
guys in the studio
yeah i haven't heard that oh so you guys
are
going to do yeah just smaller so i can
you know kind of put it in the dark deal
yeah
and no offense to blm but i don't want
to be in the dark here yeah
i'm excited for this oh man i've had so
many ivs uh to try and recover from drug
use
and uh sometimes you need a little bit
extra
sometimes you just need it man you stay
hydrating the summer's coming up man and
they got this
listen liquid iv guess that hydration
multiplier plus
immune support anybody worry about
getting sick how about it hit you with a
little vitamin c
brendon all right how about i get you
right in the mouth don't threaten them
all right man would it but but if you
punch somebody's at a wet punch
it's super wet it is yeah i keep it
juicy okay that was huh
i keep it we got the wet ass liquid ivs
hydration multiplier plus immune support
in bulk at costco
gotta have a membership though or order
online and get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com use the
code kats at checkout i'm danny
get liquid ivs hydration multiplier plus
immune
support in bulk at costco order online
get 25
off when you go to liquidives.com and
use
code kats at checkout i'm dingo
you know dustin calls him george george
boswell yeah
huh i think his friends call him jorge
either way he's fighting this saturday
ufc 261
and make bank and watch it there's three
title fights go to draftkings sportsbook
the official sportsman partner the ufc
it's putting you in the center of this
weekend's action the title fight
lu wow 26-1 odds whether you bet on
either of the title contenders whether
jorge mazel wins
kamara oozman you pick the right one
26-1
odds just bet five dollars in either
fighter to win
if they walk out with the belt you will
cash 130
dollars yeah don't worry if mma isn't
for you
draftking sportsbook also has other
options
and great odds and promotions don't
laugh at me chin
on basketball hockey and so much more
especially with that winter cold front
oh draftkings is safe secure reliable so
you can deposit withdrawal your funds
when you want download the top rated
draftkin sportsbook app now
use the promo code kats when you sign up
for to turn
dollars and 130 dollars if the title
contender of your choice wins kamar
usman or jorge mozvadal
place your bet watch the fist fly this
weekend you'll see 261 that's code kats
to turn five dollars into 130 dollars
if the fighter of your choosing takes
home the crown for limited time only at
draftking sportsbook
yep and also you must be 21 or older so
that could mean it up to any age up to
probably 110 i think is the oldest that
people ever live
new jersey west virginia or pennsylvania
only new customers
um restrictions apply new customers only
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details gambling problem call 1-800
gambler
shout out kenny rogers the other thing
we were upset about is that santino
threatened to sue him
for naming this podcast i wanted to talk
about that good friend
did he wait wait hold on no we don't
have to bring that no we definitely
should
hold on when when he came in i said dude
i love the show good friends
he goes oh yeah it's called scissor bros
i go now i call it good friends he goes
i can't santino threatened to sue us we
called it good friends
but this is according to my brother
who's never told a lie what are you
out of your mind what are you talking
about man
yeah dude santino's upset that you guys
play on words there see this is what
happened because you know that weak bert
time while you're talking okay bert tom
and um
my brother and santino they did that
they swapped podcasts right yeah
and so jeremiah was brilliant in the
fact that he was like oh we should do
one because it was april fool's week
right but also
the play on words your brother's show is
called bad friends you guys are nice in
them
good friends make sense yeah but we took
the logo we took their logo
we took we used the same artist was
there discussion first about getting the
logo or anything
it's his brother i agree look i agree i
just want to see if you even brought it
up was there a moment at the dinner
we're like hey please
i didn't deal with santino oh he's
passed the logo
jeremiah dealt with him and i didn't
deal with them but according
to bob it sounds like it sounds like you
got you
bullied them no he didn't believe it
oh you said bully outside and then he
said he threatened oh lord to sue them
if they use the name of good friends
santino probably won't take the call
because he likes to
duck confrontation
[Music]
um this could go terribly wrong that
that i don't know i just know that uh
and scissors what is it arts and crafts
show or something
no i don't know how we came up with the
name but uh we want with scissor bros
and it's not like we just it's kind of
just like a silly podcast that we do
um at jeremiah's and uh yeah it's we're
only on episode three or four it's like
brand new you got to keep it going now
yeah yeah keep it as good friends dude
yeah santino to pipe down well nobody
owns the trademark on
the name friends you can't yeah trust me
i do have trademarks all the time
you can't own the name i heard there's a
parody law as well would you say
a parody correct that's how barstool can
play like they can make tom brady shirts
michael rapport shirts like
if you do a parody you can get away with
it oh
lord so uh yeah i didn't want to ruffle
any feathers and
so we just kind of like let it be you
know jeremiah dealt with him yeah he's
back down
and we just said all right no it was
just a gag we're going to change the
name and
that's fine how upset was he according
to bob he said he hadn't
seen him that mad in his life oh wow
but now according to bob also which was
a bad which was actually a good movie
when i was growing up with
bill simmons in it yeah will you tell me
this though the
did you ever discuss it with your
brother
and be honest with me what are you
talking about like did you run it past
bobby when you're playing video games
like hey dude it means you're minding
your new podcast
it didn't be funny no no it was a
surprise it was
because we we wanted to um surprise them
yeah the surprise element
you can't surprise someone who's a theft
i don't feel like
and um it's just it's his brother he's
good friends
yeah and he's not taken away from their
show yeah
and so yeah we just let it go and then
like i don't you know i didn't
i mean if if he's getting that upset
about something
that we were just joking around about
and so what is it now is it scissor bros
good friend
it's no it's just uh see uh so jeremiah
called him just to say hey we understand
we just it was a joke can we just at
least
for our episode two can we still use the
logo
but cross it out just for branding
purposes to let people know hey
now it was a gag and now it's this is
the legit name
scissor bros and he was cool with that
yeah but he was he wanted to make sure
you you know you're not going to use
are you guys under their network or
something or do they help producers no
no we
no i don't know i said to you and bobby
just like yeah come on our network good
friends bad friends help build grow this
thing
you know that yeah like if you wanted to
be watching what friends do
yeah i never thought of it that way so
their shows should just be called bad
or just or just yeah just [ __ ] well
but i'm sure
when they see this um
they're not going to be too happy with
the drawing
well the drawing's not too good look at
the drawing okay you're drawing the
nightstalker let's get the drawing i
just want to see this woman so that we
give her some context and we at least
let people know now her eyes that big in
real life
i don't know because i just i i'm not
used to using these markers do you think
he knows
um if he gives any drawings or breathing
pretty i i need to make it i remember
here's what i remember
could you bring her up so i can see the
drawing compared to if we don't want to
see what she looks like though i thought
we're just going to have the drawing
yeah let's just yeah we'll just do the
drawing because he wants to keep her
private right
we don't yeah yeah yeah but you also
want to let her know how you feel man
i think look take 30. you think so
though i because i've never really i
always left her out of content and
podcasting and all that
you put your heart out there you can let
her know how you feel though we could
picture right now to
take you back if you want we could help
out with the [ __ ] yeah
i'm kind of doing the i'm just kind of
figuring it out on my own right now
you're dating online have you been
dating
no not real uh yeah i don't know i it's
been so long guys as far as um
oh yeah i feel you this internet uh
dating and the i i don't even know how
to dm or none
of that in any dm i don't even know how
to do it to be honest
i don't know how brent it's it's been so
long i i i don't know
it could ruin his marriage brendan yeah
i'm sure i don't i don't know
christian's a younger fella what should
what dating app should he get on what's
hot farmer's
only that can he get on farmer's only no
what is he talking about
he almost got leg implants this guy has
no idea what's going on in the world but
he's young
the only thing theo's on is farmers only
so i'd recommend going maybe
uh tinder hinge bumble i mean those are
like really
i don't even have like pictures man like
i i don't even know
yeah i don't know how to do the the
dating pictures or any of that hillary's
pizza
shop i don't know how there's a lot of
grabs out there for me yeah
so that's how you do you have to get on
dating apps and all that i guess
yeah i mean yeah you know i'm not in the
i mean theo's in the dating scene
a girl recently left me i'm just making
sure my hair looks okay in this hat
yeah you look exactly the same yeah like
one bad break from doing [ __ ]
makeup tutorials on youtube i look like
[ __ ]
skid rock um
i'm just alarmed that we had i'm just
confused if the
man outside the security man and what
did he say to you when he approached
man he changed his tone like he was cool
he's like oh okay
no problem speaks spanish yeah he's like
oh no problem and i'm like okay and then
but then when we went out he goes
he was stalking he was kind of eyeing us
in the parking lot and i was like and
i'm like i'm like running is
he staring at us and then he just walked
up to us he goes
dinero
no you said it was cool man yeah i mean
yeah and then but the thing is he got
super close to the window
like he was like kind of like flexing a
little and i'm like oh yeah like on
tiger camp
yeah so i was like what the hell is this
guy's problem you know
yeah i mean it's one thing he's like an
older dude too but he was like flexing
like he was
[ __ ] man he's got a yeah is he a nice
guy
i'd say 50 50. depends what day you get
him on if you pay him he's nice
yeah yes he has a real he keeps a tight
uh
or a loose bowel schedule that guy is in
the
restroom here constantly like i mean he
is
he must be i don't know where he what
part of mexico he's from but it is a
there's a lot of rivers in the area you
know what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh uh that guy
yeah i guess okay so this is what i got
i mean she's a lot more
prettier he's got pliorea i will say
that dude this dude has got some she's a
lot more prettier than like
you know that's a good effort though
yeah eyebrows i like the wrinkles around
her
that is also anne frank dude so let's be
honest i mean this is hor i mean she's a
lot more
way more attractive than hold that up
though let's get it going she has a wide
nose like that
um no i just i just i've done i've i've
never drawn
your inspiration from theo on the nose
there's nothing wrong with that that
actually looks a little like me yes it
does
it does it looks more like feel than
anything dude
not that anything it's a love of his
life man well
you know i'm i'm moving on and you know
what i've always been um
why don't you do a dating segment on
your show what are you talking about
like do a whole game like we did tinder
for chin like he found love
but what am i going to do for day like i
don't got caught up in a date right
thing
well no well no remember he they did
that
for me on the show what was that they
did a daily second
or dating segment for me on the show
called chinder we have thousands of
women just
throwing themselves yeah i ain't looking
for that though you know i like
i like being alone as well too you know
you know you know yeah i know do you
think
that part of you what a girl or not
daddy do you think part of you is happy
that she's gone and i hate to say that
but in a weird way are you kind of like
is it nice to be like
i just think i'm numb to it yeah i'm
just like because
you get used to being with someone and
then when you flip the script and you're
like oh i'm the single guy again it's
just like
it's like you go back to the narrative
of the movie where you're the single guy
and you're back to square one that's at
least how i feel but i bet you're
hopefully figure out your dm's because i
bet after women see this your dm's gonna
be flooded daddy
i don't know if i want that though to be
honest with you really
i don't know what you want i don't
either i mean
i mean i i love i love women and like
yeah i have
but i don't want to put them on black
but i you know you prefer playing video
games i have
like linked up with women you know for
sex
well just hook up yeah okay yeah they
come to over to the studio
man no i took over over there oh
dude you're almost like bobby before you
got hit by lightning or whatever
happened to him i feel like
that's what i feel like i feel like
you're like bobby before you got
molested you know you know bobby was a
damn good wrestler
at power at power i've heard this rumor
yeah
damn good really yeah i told you you
were supposed to wrestle varsity he
could turn a baguette into a croissant
do with his legs
he had a move called the egg roll off
bottom
you know like a kimura it was like
you're on bottom and it's a commercial
like you would you would uh
lock their arm right yeah and then roll
do a little egg roll move to his
shoulder
dude he was good that's what he was
known for he was how far are you guys in
age
three three years you're you're the
younger one yeah yeah yeah
but um can i tell you a story please
okay so
i i might have been in junior high he
was wrestling a jv tournament
in uh the uh in the gym
and he was wrestling a stud from
uh i think monte vista but he was uh he
was a asian another asian guy but uh
philip up i think filipino or hawaiian
whatever whatever
he was he was buff and it went to
overtime
and they went back into the uh wrestling
the circle
and dude like you know they had to shake
hands or something to go
ot this other cat did a bruce lee
like he did a whole like it was like
enter the dragon dude
yeah i like this and then and my brother
blew a kiss at him
hell yeah and he dude he did a double
and just oh he beat his ass yeah it was
ot
and i was i was watching you know and i
was like on the side of the mat and dude
i was so proud i'm like dude he took him
down
that's beautiful man he took him down
damn it's almost like yeah boy in the
striped pajamas or something have you
seen that
you're talking about this
this is a wrestling story man but it's
like when someone sees somebody else do
something really that they care about
they get inspired oh dude i was so proud
was bobby popular in high school
no dude oh really yeah dude he was a big
person yeah
he had like yeah dude he was kind of
like
to be honest he was like an outcast yeah
and he was in a he has seen a lot of
pictures and drawings
yeah he was in a hippie band oh uh
called uh
sounds horrible relaxed and superb oh
yeah wow uh it's
it's named after an apple oh wow and
so uh it was a hippie band uh it's on if
you could look it up on youtube
but he's talking out he was all he was
the keyboardist
oh yeah and he would be like awesome
it was it's super trippy brandon you
have to check it out a lot of drugs yeah
he was like doing stuff like this called
blackstone's a pause
laxed in superb blackstone laxton superb
yeah
it's yeah and he's uh it's a long
build-up to this song because i can't
even find it it's kind of like a
grateful dead um
it's like a grateful dead kind of a
group yeah it sounds like funeral music
like indoor outdoor funeral yeah yeah
yeah
but no he got picked on as well uh the
heavyweight art kimball um which is
picked on for being asian being
that's a chinese question san diego
there it is dude 1991.
yeah land of happiness that's
copyrighted i'm sure
it's crazy they can't make this up like
this you can't use
good friends yeah don't let santino find
out about that
oh look at this hate crime about to
happen huh
is this at the church
yeah man would they film this on
somebody's breath
this this looks outrageous
oh my god now that looks like a japanese
woman
that might have been crying outside of
our building yeah it does
we don't know who was here man yeah it's
yeah it's uh i don't know maybe public
access television maybe
publix grocery store yes um can we
uh yeah but there's a i don't know why
they don't focus on my brother there's a
at the end there's
they they turn the camera to him maybe
because he's playing the keyboard
yeah but there's a there's a segment
there he is there you go there he is oh
there he is there he is right there man
it's like journey now but reverse yeah
were you always
or was did bobby ever share the
spotlight with you or was it always
spotlight on bobby
no well the thing is when he went to
rehab like he was supposed to wrestle
varsity 105 but he like weighed 125
127 he didn't want to cut the weight i
don't think he wanted to focus on uh
snacks getting sober oh yeah oh he had
to go to rehab in high school
yeah and then yeah and then bad barbie
jesus christ
had to go to rehab in high school yeah
it was bad huh
yeah it got pretty bad yeah he got sober
young yeah
yeah for him man and but then uh he too
much sweet and sour
i was kind of like the highlight because
i
because i was you know i was doing good
in wrestling so he used to go to my
meets like cif
i i'd always choke at the state meet
like in stockton
yeah state meet chokers could be always
the name the podcast name
thank you meet chokers and then m-e-a-t
always so but it was i psyched myself
out
you psyched yourself out yeah i'd always
win san diego county cia then we got to
the big leagues kind of yeah i just
dropped the ball i dropped the drawing
okay
i don't mind yeah yeah you mind if i
draw a hat on that make you look more
like you theo huh
i'll make you look like you here's what
i'm saying is there was
just not giving her justice though she's
way prettier than that it was
do you have a body on her oh yeah yeah
no first of all this looks like i want
to say this looks like
bert and ernie fine ass girlfriend it
looks like bert's fine girlfriend
but i want to say this there was a rumor
that there was a japanese woman that's
what we got a japanese woman crying
outside of the building and this could
have been her dude okay
it doesn't look that japanese yeah no it
looks like a man that struggles with his
pronouns
yes but look before we let you go man
because we or you can stay in here
whatever you want we're going to get to
some stuff but we want we want to give
you 60 seconds to say whatever you want
to her man because i know sometimes as
men
we don't get to get things off our chest
i'll start actually i'll say 60 seconds
to the girl that
broke up with me i think that you
shouldn't have just texted me that you
were breaking up with me i think it was
kind of rude
and that you could have called or
stopped by
only was about six minutes away from
where you live or even left a note
and texting is
pretty not even i don't think it's nice
of you to do that in any way you deserve
more yeah you deserve more i deserve
more you deserve more yeah thank you
thank you yeah
all right you're trying to ten seconds
ten seconds thank you um
yeah i'm sorry for being so stubborn
uh i should have moved i should have
been more open-minded as far as moving
i should have uh yeah been more just
open-minded in general
maybe and uh i shouldn't have played so
many video games there we go
i shouldn't have i should have changed
my sleeping schedule
to complement your work schedule and
and the way you had your life set up and
yeah i'm sorry
paul says real quick i'm gonna do a
little more on yours or his online okay
and yeah i probably could have been a
little bit more night uh i just could
have been spend a little bit more time
focusing on stuff that was important to
you
and such as such as
um being ex like seeing where you worked
at
because you invited me over there and i
didn't go a lot and
[Music]
um being excited
about like things you were reading or
thinking about
okay back to you um
yeah i should have been better with my
communication as far as uh
listening i should have been a better
listener as well i should have listened
more than talking over you take the
headphones um
okay and i think i could have let you
know that i cared some i didn't really
let you know i just
kind of thought about it and didn't say
anything
back to you buddy okay um
i should have uh maybe went to more
events
family events uh
instead of staying home um okay that's a
minute okay
okay anything you want to say to her dad
you got 10 seconds to polish off
just a little bit of sentiment you want
to tell the dad to meet you yeah i'm
sorry
i'm sorry for uh messing that up
uh i should have showed up to more
family events and
been more nicer rest in peace yes r.i.p
yeah ruth bader ginsburg uh stevie
we appreciate you so much man and love
you and and thank you for being here and
i'm sorry about what happened
oh no it's all good yeah yeah it's life
you know things happen
breakups are hard dude i'm sorry you got
stranded outside oh yeah we're sorry
about that
okay and we did take a hand to nick's
face over that for you oh no
no i don't know you paid for it no it's
all good and hey
i wanna apologize uh you know like
like i'm sorry the communication got
messed up i know that was a lot of
pressure on you but that's a human
mistake
oh i also wanted to hold on you guys
sent me this and i i couldn't take it
so i wanted to give this back as well
like you guys sent me this thing
was it a check yeah there's a checks oh
dude please so
i can't no no no we're not your brother
please but the whole thing no i can't
because the whole thing is like
all i wanted to do is just get get on
and just be like i wanted to just
podcast you know
the least we could do yeah i don't know
who sent that but i i can't take that
dude
your talent no no i can't no
i can't should we leave him in here for
a few of the submissions
yeah if you want to stay in that's just
chill i don't want your friend to
i don't want your caretaker to be upset
though what is that man's name reginald
no his name's right he's my intern wren
he's a good he's he's a good dude he's
your intern
yeah a lot of people are good i wish you
would have
during the good friends segment i wish
you guys would have called your
your friend big b here oh yeah and
santino could have got into it
well i just met you today i would i
still could have called down and helped
you
i appreciate that that's impossible to
call me
if you don't know somebody yet he could
have got the number for nick but he
didn't know you
true but i see what you're saying thanks
she's got a relationship advice right
here you know how this works
yeah just i'll let you guys do your
thing all right i'll just chill well
it's relationship advice so
yeah and youtube both are in failed
relationships good evening
she live nick yeah hello
oh what's up girl what's up how are you
today hi
how are you doing i am fantastic
we got actually a guy i don't know if
you date or not do you date men or women
do you have a preference for yourself
um i am dating a man right now
well we don't want to put that on the
grill but
we're willing to offer you what's not
what's behind
couch number one or in front of couch
number one this man right here can we
show her a picture that man uh
oh on the zoom we only have the wide you
want to go
stick your head next to it never uh
never mind
oh okay anyway there's a decent man here
if something happens to your guy
yeah but you're gonna have to put up
with him playing about 14 hours of video
games
i already deal with that as it is all
right so you're open to it
okay all right that's the new erectile
dysfunction dude it's off to a good
start
what do you got for us girl what's going
on today are you going to work or what
are you doing are you
i am at work right now i'm actually on
my lunch break
oh nice nice girl yeah
i know somebody that would break you off
some lunch this beautiful little
japanese woman we got in here right here
and we'll put pictures in later but i'll
show you what he looks like a little bit
you can't see exactly
okay beautiful
okay it's a start this will start uh
what can we do for you today yeah let's
get
let's help you okay
um so basically i sent in my
um kingdors thingy i don't know if it
would
really be like relationship advice or
what have you
but um so
as a man would you let your
girlfriend have a girlfriend
do we like have to share you or do do
are we all like one big family like
three's company
no not like a throuple or anything like
that just like
um just like have a just a girlfriend
on the side oh you want a side piece
girlfriend but then you come home to
your man what's a throttle where people
vomit on each other
basically
where basically like he wouldn't like he
wouldn't be involved with a girl it
would just
be like me or now can he have a side
piece man or girl as well would you are
you okay with that
he's the one who brought it up yeah
brendan i don't think it's
she that's offering it so he's saying
who offered he's saying honey i really
think you're something special but also
we could have this other
special woman as a gr as a friend no
just her friend
yeah but yeah just my friend yeah he's
not involved in it he's saying
he's probably saying you need to get
your emotional box filled with
homegirl over here and then you know
come home and quit yapping my air off
that's what's going on
exactly yeah it's not a terrible plan
[Music]
i think that it's probably if y'all
agreed to it it seemed like a pretty
decent plan i would chart it out i'd
make a little chart
yeah i wouldn't let it go without any
documentation but you're really gonna
need to plan because what happens if he
sets up like a date night you're like oh
sorry i'm going to watch sex in the city
with
janine tonight you know now is he trying
to watch you guys have sexual endeavors
that's the thing is that he said that he
wouldn't you know want to be involved
but i'm trying to
have a feeling that he might yeah and
i'm not down for that
oh okay yeah well that's not fun well
let's ask we got a beautiful lady in
here that our beautiful uh we have a
beautiful
young man in here today who has recently
uh excommunicated from a relationship
with his brother
and his girlfriend left him so he's had
if anybody's been through rocky
relationships it's this fellow named
stevie weeby
and uh and he what do you think stevie
you opened you opened up
if oh that's a tough one let him go
brendan
i would say if he was [ __ ]
that's tough because it'd be like
you're gonna have your side thing going
but you're in a relationship with this
dude right
is that right and you guys lived well as
long as
as long as he's cool and he doesn't get
weird about it and he's open-minded
about it
oh he's open-minded about it obviously
and if he doesn't interfere with
i don't know you're gonna have to have a
talk with him i'm a little confused why
you're not open to him having fun with
the both of you
um it's not that i wouldn't be open to
it he's the one
who said that he wouldn't want anything
to do with her just because he thinks
that later on i might get mad about it
here's what's going on janet i'm going
to tell you straight up is that
ronnie if that's his name i'm going to
use fake names or real names because i'm
actually a pretty good guesser
ronnie is setting it all up to end up in
some threesomes he's just i think not
brave enough to ask for it straight up
and so he's trying to plant these little
seeds like
you guys can be on like a golf team or
whatever he's going to buy you some you
know
bocce equipment or some [ __ ] but
then he's going to sneak out and ball
both you all down
yeah he's dipping his toe in the water
yeah and that's okay
i think he's just you know it's a tough
thing to bridge with somebody so i would
meet him full
force all the way i would say look if
you want to go full force into this
let's do it but let's do it together
don't like do this bait and switch
where we invite some girl over and we're
just playing like
you know uh we're playing um pie in the
face or whatever that game is all night
you know but nobody's actually making
any sex
uh do you do you have a lady in mind
already or you'd have to seek her out
i mean i've i've got you know
i have a friend that has been a friend
for a while
and keep touching me bro we're kind of
we're kind of
thinking about it yeah there we go now
that's what we're talking about that's
what i'm getting out here
that's socialism and look i think you
got to do it
you know now's the time because here's
the thing you do when you're 70 you do
it when you're 80
not the same not as much luster
l-u-s-t-r-e
and that is a word that'll blow
brennan's brains out when he sees it
but it's a real word i think you go for
it you just have to set rules with
homeboy over there but eventually
he's gonna try sneaking his dick in
between you guys i'm not gonna lie then
you don't know that no she knows what's
up okay
yeah i don't know maybe but look at it
oh no i'm telling you
no that i'm telling you that's what's
happening okay yeah
trust me i've read this book yeah i've
seen this porno
how into she is to that girl oh yeah
jin asks how into your friend are you
just you're thinking about it because
your boyfriend said it
oh no i love her well there you go and
there you go
ladies there we go happy columbus day
dude
blm fam you got to do it good luck you
got to do it good luck out there and if
it doesn't work out at least you have a
job
that's true i do have that and you can
provide for yourself but i want to send
a pic of that girl we can
you know figure it out look i've had
enough problems also masturbating all
types of stuff so
i'd probably be willing to do it for you
guys thanks ashley thank you very much
ashley yeah sorry that wasn't really
nice to me and i'm sorry for saying that
good luck please don't sue him good luck
good luck thank you god bless you
god bless this is tanner
is this the producer from tim dillon
show oh he does look like he's close
enough what's up brother what's up
tanner hey what
what's going on guys how you doing
brother
doing pretty good actually just got some
tickets to see your show next
or two weeks from now whatever the [ __ ]
it is when you're coming to lexington
oh yeah kentucky that's right i forgot
we had that yes
how is lexington yeah oh
sorry man i keep cutting you off oh no
you're fine i was just saying how is
kentucky i've never been i've been
everywhere i've never been to kentucky
i mean you're a big bourbon guy so
obviously like kentucky's got
some of the first like uh distilleries
for bourbon ever so that's one of the
cool things
up here in lexington so there's horse
races all that junk and then
um i'll live right here beside henry
clay where queen's gambit was filmed so
that's pretty cool oh that'd be fun man
kevin from backstreet
kind of sucks though kevin from
backstreet's from lexington which one's
kevin the one that looks like a vampire
yeah tall vampire though yeah he's the
taller vampire looking feller
long-haired kind of looks like this guy
yeah kind of like
depth as well johnny depp from there
just me just
yeah i think so but he uh does not
openly claim it i
i do not believe i well i think he's
claiming he's the fact check me that i i
might be funny you're probably right
johnny depp claims he's from the
the seas because of his [ __ ] roles in
uh
oh that is that's what i'm thinking
about yeah kevin richardson
right there luxe in kentucky guess you
just won the name somebody from
lexington contest
i did this guy yeah this guy right here
uh actually kind of impressive we got
stevie in here too we got bobby lee's
brothers in here with us today you can't
see him because we don't have enough
camera space what's up man
show them the picture what's going on
big brother uh i've heard you've had
some trouble
uh getting into the studio yeah
that's really well known we already
talked about it it's all good man
everything's fine yeah he was seen
outside we actually have a picture of
him here you can see
he was seen outside crying trying to get
him that was not crying bad well
yeah it came in hot and he also got into
a fight
with our very uh parking attendant guy
yeah with a parking attendant guy who's
really cartel almost yes yeah plays no
games
people like they're always kind of antsy
they're always writing tickets
everyone's giving them an attitude so
yeah that's a good tv probably came in
there and he was just ready to
fight somebody that's fair might have
been what and it was a weekend so not a
lot of people were here and so i think
you get the you get a lot of his time on
the weekend
on the week there's like no one here
yeah there's barely anyone here yeah
yeah what do you got for us brother
all right i've got a little bit of a
debate club i thought about this in like
back in thanksgiving but i didn't spend
it in because i don't know
but uh so what holiday tradition is
worse
running a 5k on thanksgiving we're going
to church on christmas
it's both i mean not to but you know
it's
both very christian related but i feel
like it kind of ruins the holiday for
both like yeah
you either got to prepare and run on
thanksgiving and then you got
like you know christmas just want to
stay inside and hang out with the family
but
is that the is that called the turkey
trot is that what they do the turkey
trot
i think so and do you guys celebrate
thanksgiving
[Music]
all day huh what's your problem man
nothing answers
we're doing kimchi
do you think what do you think korea
what do you think we're like on
thanksgiving
yeah we try to be like everyone else man
i mean i'm with theo on this i
i didn't know i legit didn't know what i
i i
asked this question a hundred times
already i asked yeah we asked chin all
the time like for halloween i go do you
dress up
dude kimchi do you think we eat kimchi
all day yeah she needs kimchi every
holiday
we eat rice and turkey just like
everybody else
we don't eat rice in kimchi my man i
know but we add that you know you gotta
add that down it must be nice guys that
sounds better your son's better mine
yeah i'll come over to your house all
i'm saying is you're welcome to
celebrate it
yeah here we got a guy right here now
this guy what's your question bud
that's the same guy
he's the same guy you're the one trying
to morph through a mail slot
okay and i got the problem
here's the irony of it you bring us back
a piece of mail
that's out of respect though man i love
that
[Music]
here's what i want to say brother i
think if you want to do a threesome you
should do it bro
that's what i'm that's my suggestion on
thanksgiving or christmas oh yeah sorry
for thanksgiving
i think it's a new thing where some
people want to be athletic on a holiday
and so like a lot of people like
you know for years you do the you do the
fatty morning thing on thanksgiving
where you just fatten around the house
there's
first of all thanksgiving there's no
breakfast that's my big pet peeve about
thanksgiving
there's no breakfast nobody cares about
breakfast mom doesn't care about
breakfast
everybody's just waiting it's 11 30
there's nothing to eat
you're eating butter yeah it's getting
sad you know what i'm saying you're
drinking hot spoonfuls of gravy
it's getting sad bro one thing i do
recommend is
saving a new tradition is saving your
turkey gravy and actually making candles
out of it is a new thing
that people are doing which is pretty
cool yeah because it hardens up just
like a wax man
and you can find those online as well
but um
i think if you want to do athletics on
thanksgiving do it man get out there
dude maybe throw the pigskin around on
thanksgiving [ __ ] up 5k
he's not asking that that's what i'm
saying but it mix it up
traditions for thanksgiving like i feel
like you're going to ruin
just the rest of the day by going on
that run you're going to be a little bit
hungrier than everybody else
yeah yeah you're going to now i'm going
to be more tired yeah i don't want to go
to hell for this
but also you know the christian religion
we all know jesus wasn't really born on
the 25th
right that's made up we know this in
here everybody's grown man that's
something made up that's made up
he was never born on the 20th do you
think it was i know for a fact you don't
know for us i know for a fact
you've not known anything for a fact
yeah that's fact look that [ __ ] up nick
when was jesus born it's not going to
say december 25th
and i'll say this about going to
nighttime church i think it's fun on
night time because you get to do cool
[ __ ] dude i'll tell you this i went to
nighttime church one time on christmas
and on the way there we stopped at the
gas station
my teacher from school mr phillip blunt
was his name dude right
and i'm paraphrasing his name a little
bit because i don't want to get any
legalities
sure he had been detained in the in the
gas station by the gas station attendant
who was a large brother big urban and uh
he had been detained in there the guy
would not let him leave because he was
too drunk
oh no he was too drunk he's faded so mr
phillip
uh mr pia will call him mr p's in the
gas here's when i walk in i'm like mr p
merry christmas what's going on
he's like hey can i get you something to
drink and i get something to eat like
it's his house bro
he's literally stuck yes
he's like showing me around like a
little ice cream like
a little uh thing you open up in the
sliding door
so i think there's a lot of dope [ __ ]
it's a good opportunity to see who's
if anybody's husband or wife passed away
you get to see them there by themselves
or if they're going through divorce
so you can meet somebody like that good
place to meet a woman at church on
night christmas oh yeah you could do
that yeah
also black churches are lit as [ __ ] yeah
a little too lit though sometimes you're
gonna be a little bit of a gun place
when i was in the parking lot you know
what if you're in charleston for sure
pop pop for the lord you feel me so um
but yeah man praise god bro and i think
if you want to run you do it buddy we're
proud of you
all right guys well i appreciate you
he's all thanks for now
yeah hey man i'm not gonna run a [ __ ]
probably not gonna go to church on
christmas
oh damn okay well that solves it all
right it's just a bad day for me i'm
trying to stream
i've got gifts to play with
all right brother thank you man the good
work man i appreciate it yeah thank you
dang bro thanks dog nice guy huh yeah
fell apart at the end though he really
went downhill
just with his feelings but i can relax
he said i'm gonna do it either i'm very
honest
do we want to talk to our big guy george
who had the bmi oh yeah so this guy
closed out the episode 400 something
pounds you weren't here last week
last week's 400 pounds got bmi surgery
now he's down to
300 something yeah so this is cutting
weight now yeah what's the most weight
you ever cut stevie
12 pounds oh man that's high school
yeah you gotta do more than that man
because i wrestled 103. so
103. dude
man
yeah it was 98. oh 1998. they bumped it
to 103.
oh wow yeah so they bumped into what
the big dog george and we're calling to
see how he's doing
yeah what's up big dog
hello what's up brother
what's up um how are you how you doing
man you're doing good man
how are you feeling bro you lost that
weight huh
i've lost some of it i'm not all the way
at my goal yet of 260 to 250 but
i'm 106 pounds down 106. oh that's a big
deal and what are you doing right now
like since because
you had the surgery how long ago uh
april 6 so two weeks ago to the day
okay and so now what what uh what what
athletic things are like motion things
can you do
things in motion uh well normally
young people like me aren't the ones
getting the surgery it's more
an old people you know 600 pound life
kind of
[ __ ] train wreck oh yeah i heal
i healed pretty well i am already back
to boxing
and wrestling training and weightlifting
so
um i'm in it and how's that how's that
tummy feeling my man
how's that stomach doing it's doing a
lot better
about five days after i was probably
back to
80 percent about a week
eight nine days i was probably back to
95 percent
now your stomach's way smaller right
it's like half the size of ours
yes it is the size of a banana oh wow
okay that's interesting keep putting up
a banana neck
and it is also a hormonal procedure
so it takes out the portion of your
stomach
that creates the i'm hungry hormone
absolutely
so you just really not eating you're
having like a crouton you're stuffed
uh i am allowed i'm the keto kid right
now
no sugars and no carbs so my meals
as of right now consist of protein four
ounces at maximum oh wow and
uh protein can consist of meat and
cheese of right now
a little later on i can introduce uh
beans
and other type of natural plant proteins
but uh i'm soon to be back on half a cup
half a cup of greens a day good for you
man doing the goddamn
now who do you want to challenge you
want to fight somebody
uh yes i want to challenge butterbean to
the
uh jake paul versus whoever he
challenges next
me versus butterbean at 260. now what
about i got a challenge for you and it's
going a little bit to the far east
and i'm not trying to name drop or
anything but we got a fella actually in
studio today
what are you doing man that used to
fight at 98 to 103 pounds yeah some ufc
watch oh you're a clobber
yeah what are you doing man and uh this
is stevie weaving
how you doing man i'm proud of you man
you're doing the right thing we got
bobby lee
that's evie yeah you're doing the right
thing man
yeah man check out stephen i know
i like your spirits are up i like your
energy hey man brother
yeah i love you guys i love all of you
guys
i will accept that challenge
he said i love that guy but seriously i
will [ __ ] him up
what are you doing man i'm serious
there's something beautiful about seeing
people get well and want to get out on
the map man i don't care what dude
he's so big he's bigger than you never
seen ufc one and two man they did [ __ ]
like this we're trying to bring it back
lord look we would love to you wrestled
in high school
we would love to do this
yeah and then chin and nick will fight
on the same card
we might as well we've been waiting we
would love to see you we'd love to do a
wrestling match where we put it together
for you guys man to help you get back
out on your feet we're talking about man
i am out of shape dude i can get your
girl back
dude dude then you get on the mic and
give a hot promo
what do you think you have horrible
ideas man
these are horrible ideas
he's into it dude he wants me
george are you willing to accept the
challenge from himself i didn't
challenge him my man
i didn't challenge him to accept the
challenge yeah what are you guys going
to do
ufc one vibes dude you're afraid to
first of all i'm an [ __ ] dog you're
afraid to fight this formerly [ __ ]
big guy where where do you live yeah
there we go
i'm an hour south of chicago let's go
meet him at deep dish come on steve now
look we're going to sweden to be my
coach
come on now look i think you guys could
we could easily put this together and
steve
get the singlet like we're going to do
the whole thing i think so we'll film a
countdown with you
do you know how to wrestle brother uh
i'm
being trained by a former uh almost
arizona college wrestler right now okay
valencia valencia the valencia brothers
shout out nico my boxing coach
hey
time though you got time oh lord we're
just talking about not applying yourself
step
step so we're going to have to wear the
huh the tights
yeah he's got to wear his real tight is
yeah no is this wwf
rules or no this is ufc one rules no i
think this will be wrestling 45 minutes
straight
the cardio king over there dog he said
45 minutes i think i think i think after
seven it's gonna get a little sloppy
you like this but here's why i like
here's why i like it because it gives
you a chance to
do something commit to something which
you didn't do
and it cost you this lady anne frank
okay
it gives you a chance to do something
and get out there
and this guy could have died this guy's
almost dead look at him and it gives him
a much respect man
yeah you did the right thing so i think
it's something cool to see people that
are getting well
in their own ways mentally and
physically to get out of the mat and
just do something
for fun get out of your comfort zone
dude yeah and then your
your old your old sweetie pizza is a
trainer i would need a whole bunch of
stuff
we're gonna take care of all that you
need it you got you got big brown you
got malik b
come on
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
how about this we'll play warzone let's
just play some war zones
that's what got you in now if you're on
war zone i'm gonna give you my gamer tag
no no hey man let me do my thing this
needs to be a physical activity
let's do our war zone thing brother
we'll have a good time i'll use my
bullfrog
we'll drop in we'll drop in the
resurgences
that's why you lost your girl oh no yeah
call of duty probably promoted to the
health crisis in america
of young fat kids yeah dude that's what
i'm saying
this guy definitely man i love you
george thank you much love brother being
here
we'll find a way to get you guys on the
mat man let's see what we can do maybe
we can fly each other to arizona or
something yeah let us keep working on
him but we know you're
in my man keep up the good work man
don't cheat on that diet
bless brother it's a thick boy summer
dude thick boy summer
summer all that george we want to say
black queen i want to check in with you
in a couple weeks yeah we want to check
in with you in a couple weeks so keep it
going all right
keep us posted my man 100 i will love
you big dog
gang baby hey peace man
have a good day you too brother wow can
you call him fat boy
i didn't mean to it was an accident i
thought you wrote fat boy on a card and
hold up would you hold that
i think chin did that for some reason it
sounds awesome like
well he has the sir he had the surgery
for fat people he knows he's working
no he knows what's up i mean that's the
elephant in the room no pun intended
now that is rude i feel like you called
him
fat kid huh did i
yeah you went come on you're not gonna
wrestle this fat kid yeah you promoted
the whole thing like that
that was your entire pit at least i
showed up for you here today i know
i know i know i know you didn't even
show up
you you wrestled in high school you're
gonna have advantages
dude i'm out of shape bro i get tired
playing video
dude walking i'm out of shape but this
is
once he grabbed me like i would try to
do like a single
you know you get them down those faints
what i do like a john smith like low
ankle pickers
ankle pig how am i going to keep him
down
you're going to choke him out yeah i'm
like 137 pounds or something what about
jake who's that wrestler right now
that's hot
kyle dake yeah he's hot he's a dog i
mean he's good at wrestling
you know he just beat jordan burroughs
yeah i saw him be jordan bruce you see
that match yeah
you see it yes you guys know who jordan
burroughs is and he handled this stud
super stud cornell four-time ncaa
champion right there in four different
weight classes monsters
four different weight classes and his
muscles are just made out of different
stuff oh he's dude take that motivation
and then beat the big dude that's kyle
did we work for one week we were
dude you know what this is going to be
you know what this can be oh my god do
you guys not know who he is yeah
i do yes i don't i just
as your girlfriend
with your name with your branding of
your show you guys are comparing me to
kyle dave
yeah welcome to kingston what is wrong
with you
dude no i you you are not you know what
it
is
we see potential he doesn't yeah no we
see the potential you don't see dude
one week you and me game planning to
take his big ass out dude
do you not know i haven't wrestled in
like he's never wrestled no
do you use wrestling he's getting coach
right now no he's not
arizona no he said he said they got no
he said the guy's from here
man i listened he said he's got trainers
he's got a whole team
uh uh training he's one person arizona
he doesn't have brendan and theo
oh and we have your back dude you do
you do yes you wrestle in high school
dude i have i have a uh
stripe on my white belt but a one stripe
wipe out
man he i would take him no this is what
thank you this is what would happen i
would take him down
maybe if i'm lucky we're getting him
down i would have to do in the first 20
seconds
yeah we're doing that because he gets a
hold of him you have 45 minutes
i wouldn't last 45 seconds dude we're
throwing faint yeah yeah
ankle pig like randy maybe
bad attitude should be your name your
podcast no i'm a realist man
that's not bad attitude i'm being real
about it i'd take him down i would try
to
we got speed you're gonna get his back
hold him down on my hand you don't have
to where'd you get him get to his back
dad put him in that crab wonton dog yeah
put him in that [ __ ]
i'll just tell him man [ __ ] care
about yourself
bro oh crap one time you don't think
bert and ernie's sister [ __ ] escaped
from [ __ ] alcatraz he's out for
inspiration dude lord he okay so
it's all right i'm going to call you an
idiot i want to apologize put him on his
back
yeah could i get a pin no you're going
to choke him out
it's going to be what rules are we using
submission wrestling i don't know how to
shoot right no punching
no punching no striking submission
wrestling he that's not what he said he
was doing this
well we'll set the rules i don't know
what he was doing he is a sophomore in
high school
really yeah
cause i'm older and you've had
heartbreak now we're talking dude you
can fit through a male 1 you don't say
that changes the whole game
what i'm saying you got the inner hand
this kid's a sophomore i think so i
think
dude because you know what it might [ __ ]
him up the mental edge yes
because i have an experience yeah i went
to school at cif three times
now this this the stevie we know dude
but i have a chance you didn't say he
was a sophomore
i thought he was in college or older no
no no no he's a young man
okay no life he's got a lot of
confidence i have to give him that
right he does have a lot of confidence
he'll just get surgery there's a lot of
beautiful stuff going on between the two
of you guys i think you know and that's
i like seeing you in this place a little
bit better man where you're at this like
you're at least willing yes a lot of
it's willingness man talking about
willing to freaking change your life
right right so you want me to fly so
where is this event going to be i'll
figure it out probably we'll do it we'll
make it easier on you we're guessing
you're a hampton inn probably somewhere
in between here and there
maybe you guys probably had a red roof
in
dude that's usb1 that's you guys that
could be you dude
too much so i'm the white climate red
roofs too much crime at red roofs
a lot of drugs at the red roofs how much
does he weigh again i just want to try
to do something he's wasting
360. right now he's down to 240 right no
that's his goal
he's he's down how much does he weigh
365. he was 470. he was 365.
but he's going to continue losing
realize it doesn't matter what it wants
if he gets his weight on me i'm done let
me tell you something about yourself
okay
apparently you don't have good mirrors
at your house what are you talking about
what you don't see dude is that you're
capable okay
you're a capable little worm you're a
capable little worm dude
dude your nickname's the worm we just
gave you that yeah
when i could squirm out of it dude you
almost fit through a [ __ ] mail slot
you lost this woman i know but dude once
he gets his
if what if he takes me down he's well
then we'll see what happens
and he puts his weight on me bro quit
talking about it that's the world where
the worm comes in
that would be a nightmare if you had not
taught me a midnight man
but we're not going to worry about that
dude you're going to ankle his big ass
what about that
because i'm just you would like to see
that that's the thing
that's the whole thing all the talking
about it is just [ __ ] man
you can do it though
i know that nick that's it are you open
to it yeah i am
that's all we need out of you yeah i'm
open to it it's a step in the right
direction
yeah i'm open to it i want you to keep
that check too man you deserve no no
i can't dude this is what you're gonna
do i can't i refuse i have to listen to
your
freaking refusal i'm telling you tell
them something you're gonna get in shape
you're gonna get in shape you're gonna
beat that big boy you're gonna take that
check and then you change the name of
your podcast to good friends
and then santino has a problem tell him
to see me and theo oh we can't do that
yeah we're doing that no no we already
had the talk
tell him to meet me at manhood no we had
to
die we can't he he'll lose his mind no
he won't huh he'll lose his mind if he's
not with me and theory won't yeah
what are you gonna do you're gonna i'm
gonna hold him down and dye his hair
what are you doing
he's talking about lawyer like you can't
yeah you can't trademark the
the term friends yeah but still it's
like we gave him our word
and so it's scissor bros yeah
you don't like it gabe dude you don't
like the name you gave up
you guys got bullied by santino dude
the podcast name is good friends dude
vietnam baby forever dawg
we love you and you love us dude and
we'll see you in the future dude
and shout out to whatever the guy's name
in the beginning that little kid who was
in here with the [ __ ] leg extensions
yeah man uh i'm in austin this weekend
we added the show thursday thursday
night vocal and gas company oh i got
some shows coming up we got a new tour
that we're going to launch in about
these back on the road
about two weeks we're going to know that
we're just going to go on sale with
tickets but it's going to be
it's going to be a little bit different
here a little bit later this year
but uh so i think next week i'll
announce some uh tickets
i'm in austin this week and then we just
add to the books lexington kentucky and
houston texas
see you soon stevie where you got any
dates no no but scissor bros uh podcast
definitely uh
scissor bros aka good friends to our
youtube channel uh steviewbandcamp.com
he has an album instagram slash
q-u-a-n-g-o-u
um kwang-woo is my uh korean name
you're cute how come we didn't play any
of his albums no no you don't have to
it's all good sometimes i follow real
daily dude thank you guys so much for
having me we love you man
thank you so much dude it's so good to
see you man and i want to apologize
about everything
i honestly i want to do what are you
going to apologize i want to apologize
about everything that happened there
talking about it you're good okay i'm
here
and it's all good yeah but yeah it was
nothing personal i mean it was a total
accident and i know yeah
no it's all good news it'll be a great
time for them to speak up right now yeah
we cleared it all up i'm very sorry and
i'm glad
no no you're good man it was a great
episode thank you for watching
that was fun man shout out to shout out
to you shout out to carla too wasn't her
name
[Music]
i'm ready to go i need a sponsor i am a
monster about to open up with this at my
concerts flow is contagious browser
outrageous thicker than girls that are
instagram famous damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude they
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
travis couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
king and a sting beast
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you